عام 20 22 عام وظيفي او عامل مسار المهني
كما يطلق عليه موقع فوربس عام شهد اكبر
التغييرات في النظام الوظيفي بعد عامين
قاسيين بفعل الوباء واثاره السلبيه على
الناس هذا الموظفون حول العالم نظرتهم لما
يريدونه في مكان العمل الموظفون يريدون
الشروط عمل مريحه ساعات مرنه وسط احتجاجات
عماليه في دول عده لرفع الاجور مع موجه
التضخم التي تضرب العالم في الولايات
المتحده شهدنا اربعه ملايين استقاله كل
شهر بين يناير واكتوبر خلال للعام الجاري
وهي نسبه اعلى بكثير من مستويات ما قبلنا
وشاهدنا ايضا شركات تكنولوجيا عالميه
تتخلى عن خدمات الاف من موظفيها في يوم
وليله والتوتر في فرنسا
وقلص الدول ومنها مدن عربيه ايام الدوام
الاسبوعيه الى اربعه ايام لتحفيز المو فين
على الانتاجيه وهو ما اختبرته الشركات
البريطانيه ايضا على مدار السته اشهر
الماضيه
[موسيقى]
اذا عشت متردده ازاء تحول وظيفه طرق على
مسار المهني هذا العام ترددات طلعات نزلات
لا استقرار عاطفي ازاء المهنه فجاه وكان
السحر حصل هناك اقتناع هناك رغبه في
الاستمرار في المضيفه نفس المكان كيف نفهم
هذا التقييم للوظيفه وللمصاري الوظيفه
والقرارات في نهايه العام
جميل جدا اللي تكلمت عنه هذا اسمه
رغبه فرصه قدره يعني احيانا انه يكون
الشيء اللي جاني في البدايه يكون بغير
رغبتي انا طلب مني او امريكا
في مجال المهني في مستقبلي في هذا المكان
القدره هل انا قادره على الشهاده ولا لا
فلما اكتشف نفسي الواحد احيانا يحتاج يعطي
نفس الفرصه انه يستمر لمده سنه عشان يشوف
في المواسم يشوف الفرق
يشوف الاشياء اللي تغيرت على مجال حياته
لما اخذ هذه الفرصه الجديده هل الان تغيرت
رغبتك ولا لا حول نظره غير نظرتك الامور
تتغير الامور تحول الامر من ان انا وجبرت
او انا انطلب مني اني افعل حاجه وانا ما
كنت اخبارها فيها الى شيء صرت حاسه اني
مستمتعه يومي طويل اجلس مع اولادي اقدر
اروح العب رياضه مقابل اصحابي وباصحى من
الفجر نظام حياتي غير بعد ما اخذ صباح
العربيه مثلا يعني ههه الفكره الثانيه ههه
انه عندنا اربع تقييمات نادين وسهام جدا
والله الان في المملكه من المتوسطه يطلب
منك الطلاب يختاروا مسارهم في الثانويه
تنويه صعب جدا على على طفل خلينا نقول
انسان مراهق في في المتوسطه انه يختار شيء
وهو ما هو عارف كيف اكتشف نفسه هنا نقول
لهم يا جماعه تعالوا نسوي اختبارات
عشان يكتشف نفسه انا بدل ما ادخل تقنيه
طبيه وادخل اشتغل في همم الكريب اعمل
فطائر في مول واجلس من مضيف الماضي يشتغل
اتش ار بعدين اكتشفوي ليش التخطط هذا لما
يجيك تقرير يقول لك هذا افضل شيء يناسبك
تفضل طيب الدول المتقدمه كلها تعمل كده
طيب اذا كان الموظف متردد ما الخيارات او
ما السبيل لكي يتخذ قرارات اكثر همم
نسميها اثمار دكتور نفسي تراند
جميل جدا
لانه الان زي ما قلنا الجدول نعمله سهام
انه نحط نقيم من عشره كل رغبه من الرغبات
عندنا مثلا خلينا ناخذ المثال بشكل واضح
تقديمه الاخبار صباح العرب اوكي كم رغبه
هيك في صباح العربيه وكمان رغبتك في اخبار
من 10 بعدين فرصتك
ممتاز الفرصه الفرصه يعني ايش ايش
المستقبل اللي هيكون هنا يا صباح العربيه
او مستقبل اني اقابل اشخاص واكون علاقات
راتبي ممكن يزيد مكانه ممكن تزيد هناك انا
في مجموعه كبيره من المتحدين ومن الاشخاص
انا متميزه في اكثر مكان هنا الفرصه
اعطيني من عشره من عشره صباح العربيه كان
من 10 اخيرا القدره القدره ما شاء الله
تبارك الله انتم الاثنين عندكم القدره
رائعه انتم في مكانكم في ذكائكم لغوي اها
بنفس الوقت انتم ثنائي عجيب انا ماني عارف
كيف لو وحده